what about kelly kelly clarkson's
husband
what is he getting he's getting paid out
by kelly clarkson oh they're preen up
held up she had a prenup i saw her got
onto the prenup don't be upset at that
[ __ ] no you decided to have do you think
he was the one that sprung the premium
apparently her uh number from what i'm
understanding was higher than the prenup
that he got awarded and then she was
able to be like nah i got the [ __ ]
prenup honor the prenup kind of like dr
tray and nicole oh he's a bitch-ass dude
then yeah why are you trying to get more
you signed up
yeah you're a [ __ ] 150 000 of spousal
support plus 450 45 000 in child support
every month
so he's getting 200 000 from kelly
clarkson a month yeah yeah that's crazy
that's the settlement number yeah i
don't know if that's monthly yeah nearly
200k a month
child support
how dare you want more dudes yeah i want
to be like yeah finally we got it back
but you are a loser yeah you were a
loser the only way i can support this is
if he worked for her in some capacity if
he like had was some sort of like side
manager you know sometimes like
eventually you just your business
becomes so big that
the it is more lucrative for you to have
your family working for you than them
working regular jobs
like for example let's say he was not
exactly the manager but the day-to-day
what do they call the pm or something
like that or he's like operations guy or
something something like that right like
and you would pay your operations
manager 200 000 a year anyway your
husband has a skill set that's going to
make him seventy five thousand dollars a
year
just do that
now he gets fi now he gets fired because
you're no longer together right so what
is he supposed to do
he gave up his life so he could work
with you 150 000 a month or a year
it's close to 200 000 a month according
to you know who he is he's the dark
knight he's not the hero we want but
he's the hero we need
we need more of these dudes to get over
these girls so women start being like yo
what the [ __ ] dude yeah this is [ __ ]
they spousal support we need more of
these guys we don't respect him but we
need him i mean look if that's the
prenup i'm okay y'all made an agreement
yeah i'm cool with it 100 and she should
be cool with it too yeah but if you're
asking for more than the agreement you
are a [ __ ] ass dude go get a job you
loser make some [ __ ] money provide
for your family what a pathetic
[ __ ] to just get a check he's
also white he's also gonna get paid
enough say again he's also gonna get
paid enough yeah you know i mean it's
not like the prenup was like 20 000 a
year like yeah he's getting paid i think
the prenup was you know crazy why do you
get more spousal support than child
support that's crazy yeah i don't know
support yourself [ __ ] yeah maybe
the kids are older i don't know but yeah
he sought 400 000 it's about spousal
support oh he's a he's a piece of [ __ ]
yeah oh he's a real piece of [ __ ] yeah i
mean what a loser dude yeah absolutely
what an absolute [ __ ] loser what's
this guy's name
uh let me check right here brandon
blackstock yeah no he's you're a loser
brandon blackstock you're a [ __ ]
loser go get a job make some money dude
there's something about a man
getting a handout
it is pathetic i don't respect it that
being said i'll take that ppp loan
no but you don't understand like
something ugh imagine every month here's
your allowance
i would i would sign the check your
allowance
i think that kelly clarkson should be
able to put the check in whatever way
she was like the memo the memo should
say baby's allowance baby's allowance
here's baby's allowance enjoy wow
ugh disgusting are you kidding me 150
thousand dollars you got to pay a month
wow it's just balling
all right what else we got
oh you heard about this nurse in germany
no what's going on okay so as a nurse in
germany we don't know yet last i checked
if it was politically motivated or
if she just like dropped like a ton of
vials of the vaccine yeah we don't know
if it's one or the other or both but she
injected 8 000 germans with saline
solution instead of vaccine ah
so now they're having to go back through
and figure out everybody she might have
injected with vaccine right and you
don't know for sure if it's vaccine or
actual
saline or actual vaccine yeah and they
are having to come in and get
re-vaccinated so i think 2400 so far or
something have been revaccinated but
like you don't know time will tell if
this woman is a hero or a villain
because if the vaccine ends up you know
causing [ __ ] cancer or doing
something crazy and she gave 8 000
people saline yeah that's a lot of lies
she's the corey ten boom of vaccinations
who's that she hit a bunch of jews in
germany
so she's like schindler this is
schindler's list oh my god
but if she ends up killing these
[ __ ] because they all get
delted out of here and she's hitler
hitler
my god
this is really interesting we got to
keep tabs on this story the motive of
the nurse was who was not named was not
clear but she had aired skeptical views
about vaccines and social media posts
no she was anti-vaccine how do you not
like check a person's background if
they're going to be administering the
vaccine like just go through their
social media in the past two months and
just see what they're saying about it
yeah i don't want anti-war how [ __ ]
hard is that i don't want a general
that's like a pacifist yeah i mean i'm
like i don't care you're not busy you're
hospital administrative you're not busy
like [ __ ] frontline workers you're
backlined this is all you got to do
let's just see what this [ __ ] thinks
this is free healthcare you'll enjoy
that [ __ ] yeah this is free healthcare
this is what you get you know what else
is free saline exactly
nothing you get some sugar water in your
shoulders you know i want to know all
like the the husbands whose wife was
complaining about the vaccine she's like
yeah i just feel super sick like
i can't do anything we can't have sex
tonight i just have a terrible headache
and he's like he's like [ __ ] you lied
the whole time yeah she's like no it's a
saline reaction i think it's also gonna
be real like you know people were like
dude i got the vaccine i barely even
felt it i was flying yeah yeah yeah yeah
for a rude awakening yeah
yeah [ __ ] man a bunch of those people
are probably anti-vaxxed now they're
like this actually didn't do anything i
got covered twice my grandma died
sucks yeah
oh word she could have killed thousands
of people like they're gonna have to go
through and see all these patients and
if they give kova to anybody and any of
those people died their murder she's
responsible for because the reason i i
just remember this i completely forgot
but i think the reason that i got the
vaccine is so i could see my parents
yeah i was i just felt so horrible that
i could give them yeah the virus and it
would kill them yeah and uh oh my god so
many people
probably got the vaccine for the same
reason when to go visit their old ass
parents yeah merck merc finally
holy [ __ ] yeah that's the name of one of
the pharmaceutical companies germany is
murk so
that's true
what a horrible name
you